would you like a chocolate oh thank you
Forrest Gump was in Savannah Georgia a
town with interesting history but tour
guides say the number one question I get
is where's the bench and Forrest Gump
Michell free no offers walking tours we
are gonna do a 90 minute history tour of
Savannah she gets good reviews from
customers but her business almost didn't
get off the ground because Savannah's
politicians say to be a tour guide you
have to get a license I had to pass a
college-level history exam with tons of
obscure gotcha questions it could be
three to five months of studying and
studying it because it was about 120
pages
I had to map out where I was standing
what I was saying tour guides need
licenses in some cities you have to have
a license just to tell stories dick
carpenter author of the book bottleneck
errs gaming government for power and
private profit says Savannah's rules
like those in many cities creates so
many hurdles for entrepreneurs not only
did Michelle have to pass a difficult
history test she also had to do a
criminal background check which meant
she had to give a urine sample and a
blood sample she also had to go through
a physical fitness test and she had to
pay fees to the city as a result a
hundred dollars and yet the test asked
no questions about subjects covered by
the most popular tours you know the most
popular tour in Savannah is a ghost tour
so she complained to a city official
there's no ghost questions on this test
and he goes because ghosts aren't real
there were no questions about the making
of Forrest Gump
either stupid even if guys give Forrest
Gump tours ghost tours or food tours
they had to take the test the city was
making a nice amount of money for people
failing this a lot of people think that
this fee is just another money grabbed
by the city alderman Bill Durance says
it's important
licensed tour guides I hear a lot of
tour guides saying things that make me
cringe because it's just not accurate
information and so the the licensing and
the testing I thought it was a good idea
just to
people had the accurate information
politicians and a bunch of other cities
agree they demand the tour guides pass
tests the turning point for Michelle
came when she got sick when I told them
hey I don't think I could pass the
physical this year I was actually told
by a city official well I guess you're
gonna have to find another occupation
there were a couple of points that maybe
went a little too far in the licensing
process having to have the physical exam
periodically maybe the cost of the test
they basically said if you don't like it
you can sue us and when they said that
that's what I did with the help of the
law firm the Institute for justice she
sued Savannah and Savannah removed its
licensing rule so how does that go down
you bring the suit and they sheepishly
say oh yeah you're right it's the First
Amendment issue mmm I wish it were that
easy
there's discovery depositions are taken
and so the city often loads months often
years they realized that this was in
fact if a First Amendment issue and they
stood to lose Savannah was just one of
their victories you want a Washington DC
tour just $10 that's the capital behind
me this is the IRS building well I can't
tell you that
that's illegal Washington DC once
demanded the guides have a license so I
joined this Segway tour they try to make
sure that people get a proper tour we
give him a proper tour I mean I've
passed a bar exam I know how to give a
proper tour the Institute for justice
sued Washington two and one so now at
least in DC and Savannah tour guides are
free to work the free market is taking
care of itself bad tour companies don't
last it's been a pleasure walking with
you today she's right competition
protects consumers better than licensing
laws ever will but politicians always
want more control over you a little by
little we've managed to get control of
some things but we still don't have
control over a lot yes you do your
bottlenecks are everywhere so I'm glad
there are people out there trying to
stop them in our next bottleneck our
video will cover the fight over food
trucks I could have lost it all
you